Mikey Jenny is back with us today to
discuss the prevalence ofnosticism in
all forms of media. Gnosticism is a
second century belief system that turns
Judeo-Christian doctrine and its beliefs
upside down. A world view in which Jesus
is the enemy and Satan is the savior.
Have you been enchanted by such
doctrine? Let's find out. Welcome back,
brother Mikey. Thank you for having me
again. For those of us that missed the
first episode that you were on, catch us
up. So, it was basically my testimony
and how powerful the media is to
influence me as being a young Christian
child to being enticed by the occult and
witchcraft and things like that. So,
media is very powerful and we know that
this is something that happened to you
when you were a teenager. Yes. Do you
think it's still prevalent now? Oh, even
more so. Yeah. the the media is just
over time it's like the frog in the
kettle. You know, we started out with
things like Leave It the Beaver and it
seemed all good, but now we're at a
point where we're entertaining ourselves
with shows called Lucifer, you know.
Well, we talked about it being
predominantly or at least in the last
episode a visual format, but do you
think it's in other forms? Uh yeah, it's
in video games, kids movies, TV shows.
Basically, Satan has found a powerful
tool and he wants to get his gospel
message in all forms of media from all
age ranges. So, let's get into it. Let's
dig right in. Tell me about nasticism
and how you found it in media.
So,nosticism, it's basically an
inversion of Christianity where Lucifer
was an angel that came into the garden
and told Adam and Eve, "Look, God's
trying to keep you from having
knowledge. He doesn't want you to be
smart. He doesn't want you to eat that
fruit because you'll be wise like him."
And so they it's a Luciferian doctrine.
They believe that he was a good angel
freeing Adam and Eve from this
tyrannical god that put him in this
garden prison. And so that's the way
they believe. And when you know what to
look for and you see this template,
you'll see it in all forms of media.
When you taste of this fruit, right,
you'll know whether it's from God or
from Satan. And if it goes against the
word of Christ, we know it's from Satan.
That's right. We have to test everything
according to scripture. Test all the
spirits, right? So I think the
misconception with media, it affects us
all. You know, as a Christian, we're
like, look, I don't drink, smoke, cuss,
fornicate, all these things. But media
impacts us all. Even when you're pumping
gas at a gas station, there's a a TV in
your face. And so the big push back is,
well, I know the difference in reality
and fiction. I know that this is, you
know, fairy tale. It doesn't affect me
is what they say. But secular sources
and everybody knows that media is
powerful. That's why uh you know
corporations will spend a billion
dollars on a 60c or not even 60 seconds
10-second ad because they're going to
get the money back. That's right. We had
Dr. Walsh here and he actually brought
that out as well that it's we're not
just dealing with entertainment. We're
dealing with something that happens
chemically to us when we're watching TV.
It actually puts us in a trance state,
bypasses the frontal lobe and allows
direct access to what helps us govern
ourselves. That's exactly right. You
know, Satan's after our mind. That's
what it's all about. And if he can get
in there any way he can, that's his, you
know, he's he's getting one over on us.
So, I think a lot of people, you know,
when we put up these guards, like, oh,
it's just entertainment. We're really
allowing the enemy to to deceive us. But
we wrestle not against flesh and blood.
That's what Ephesians 6:12 says. And,
um, actually, 2 Corinthians 10:4-5 talks
about pulling down the strongholds and
casting down imaginations and bringing
into captivity every thought to the
obedience of Christ. So things we think
about are important. Our imagination is
actually really key in this. That's
right. In Genesis, it tells us that
men's imaginations were wicked and
that's why the earth had to be cleansed
of its sin. So here we are again, right?
And the Lord says that when he returns,
it'll be like the time of Lot, right?
Yeah. Are we here? Yeah. And people are
defending it, saying, "Well, it's just,
you know, using your imagination." But
that's where sin starts. You know, Jesus
said to look upon a woman, to lust after
her is the same as committing adultery.
And even science is backing this stuff
up. When when you watch things, when you
observe things, your brain fires the
same way as if as if you're doing it
yourself. So, I have a couple examples
here, but I want to talk about
propaganda. You know, propaganda is just
painting someone in a biased light. You
know, you could have a a politician and
somebody could spray paint horns on them
and suddenly you think by a picture
alone you think that person's bad or
somebody this association just takes
over. Yeah. The same picture could have
a halo drawn over it and sun rays and
now they look like a savior. So Satan's
doing that with God. He's putting God in
the stories and in Christ and using all
the same character traits but painting
him in a wrong light. You know, you
Satan is um he's a master at deception.
A lot of things he spoke was truth,
right? But it's that 10% error, that 1%
error. 1% error is not truth. No. And so
if he can paint God in a bad way over
time, repetition, watching these things
over and over and over, we'll begin to
change our minds. We subscribe to that.
Right. That's right. So Jesus, you know,
he he was a powerful storyteller. In
Matthew 13:34, it says, "All these
things spake Jesus unto the multitudes
in parables, and without a parable spake
he not unto them." Because stories are
powerful. When we want to teach our
child to not tell lies, it's a lot more
powerful to tell the story of the sheep,
the boy who cried wolf. That's right.
Because there's a lesson wrapped up in
that. And and the story sticks with the
kid just like music. Very powerful.
You're using the imagination in a
productive manner. That's right. That
leads them to light. There's nothing
wrong with imagination if it's used the
proper way. So, Satan knows this. He's
using the same method. He always takes
what God does and he perverts it. So,
Satan is saying, "Hey, you tell stories.
I can tell stories, too. And I have a
million-dollar budget with all these
special effects and it's hypnotic to
people. They're drawn to it. When they
see that trailer, they'll they'll line
up. People aren't lining up to get into
church." No, they're not. But they're
camping to see the next movie. Right.
Right. And Satan's not going to let that
type of opportunity just go by. He's got
an agenda. And so a question we get
asked a lot is, do we think all these
Hollywood actors and directors are just
in a smoke filled room saying like, "How
can we deceive the Christians?" No, we
don't believe that. But we believe that
you're you're inspired by someone. If
you're walking with God, if you're
asking God to inspire you, then you will
be inspired by him. But if you're not
and you're walking in the things of the
world, that's a perfect opportunity for
Satan to give you, you know, visions and
scripts and all that, dreams and
abilities that you didn't have
otherwise. And that's why they often use
celebrities to package the devil's
messages. Yeah. Beautiful people. And a
lot of these people will openly tell
you, uh, James Cameron and the lady that
wrote Harry Potter, they're like, "Hey,
this came from a dream. I wrote it
down." And now they're the bestselling
movies of all time. The actors will say
the same things like, "That wasn't me
out there." like when I go on the set,
something else takes over. And some of
them will go as far as to say that they
pray to spirits and they channel and all
that. And some do it intentionally.
Yeah. I did uh see a news uh reel about
a young man who's on Snowfall. Okay. And
it's I think a subscription-based uh
program and he plays a drug dealer and
he said that he had come to a block in
his process and that he went in the
corner and he said, you know, Satan,
help me. and that he did so and that it
was like a one take and he was able to
get through it and it was convincing and
compelling but it came with some
repercussions and that was that he kept
having demonic dreams such that he had
to call his mother and say mama pray for
me and you talked about that
intercessory prayer that's right and so
it does it creeps in I think a lot of
people do this unaware you know they
call it method acting and things like
that but just some examples I want to
give some examples of of how this media
affects all groups of people because you
might say well I don't watch all that
dark stuff I just watch. I like The
Matrix, you know, a sci-fi movie. It was
one of my favorite movies of all time.
But in the movie, the the main
antagonist are three beings that talk
alike, look alike, sound alike, finish
each other's sentences. Who does that
make you think of? The Trinity. The
Godhead. Yeah. So, the Godhead or the
Trinity being the villain and they are
actually known as the secret police. So
they're what what happens in the movie
is he's told by someone else. Lucifer
told Adam and Eve that this world you're
in is is not the real world that you can
eat this fruit and have your eyes open.
The same thing happens in this movie.
Morpheus who is wearing a a long trench
coat that has scales all over it. You
know it's very symbolic. And he offers
him, he says, "Hey, I can open your eyes
if you take the red pill," which is very
symbolic of the apple that Adam and Eve
ate from. You know, we don't know if it
was an apple, but it's often portrayed
that way. Or he says, "Or you can take
the blue pill," which blue represents
the law. He says, "You can take the blue
pill and stay in La La Land, or you can
take this red pill, have your eyes open
and see the truth." And so in the scene,
Neo, the main character, he decides and
he takes the red pill. And as he takes
the pill, the camera goes back to
Morpheus and he gets this evil grin and
there's lightning and thunder behind him
just as if, you know, God saw this and
was angry. And so the devil has
basically just planted something in your
mind so subtly and you just think it's
entertainment. Yep. Entertainment. And
and sometimes even people associate it
in a different way. They're like, "Well,
this is kind of like waking up to secret
societies or something, but you have to
just step back and look at all the
imagery. There's so much tied into it."
And the the directors openly said, "Yes,
it is a Gnostic movie." So, they agreed.
And so, when Morpheus takes Neo and he's
he's kind of given them a tour of this
world that he's been living in, he's
saying, "Look, everything's black and
white. Everything's rules and everything
is, you know, based on this system, but
that's our enemy." And so they walk,
it's everything's so symbolic. They walk
against the traffic of people that are
wearing just black and white going
across them. They're going against the
grain. And then Morpheus says,
"Teachers, lawyers, carpenters. These
are our enemies. Name one person who was
a teacher, a lawyer, and a carpenter."
Jesus. Jesus Christ. So there is
definitely an attack. You see that
Morpheus is dressed like the serpent,
offering the the ability to have your
eyes open and then walking against
rules.
and telling you that teachers, lawyers,
and carpenters are the enemy. And so, in
the end of the movie, Neo ends up having
a conversation with the Matrix or the
the whole system, and he's saying,
"You're afraid of us, and you you put us
in this system full of rules, but I'm
going to tell people of a world without
rules and without you, and this is what
we're being fed." And and you just think
about in the last days, we're going to
be in a world of lawlessness.
And yeah, our flesh, we don't like
rules. We think like, oh, you're telling
me what I can and can't do. But imagine
a world with no rules realistically. So
that reminds me of the It's basically
like an Gnostic gospel that they're
promoting. And I remember there was a
movie called, I believe, Harry Truman,
and it was pretty clear, you know, that
Oh, the Truman Show. Truman Show. That's
what it was. Same thing. Yeah. That he
was put in this perfect world. And he
was even being watched by the producer
in the sky who called himself the
creator. He said, "I'm the creator of a
TV show." And when he realizes that he's
on this set, he opens up the door and
it's complete darkness. And the creator
speaks to him and says, "I've been
watching you your whole life. I've I've
put you in a perfect world. There's
nothing but pain and misery out there."
But he's on a reality show and
everybody's watching and they're on the
edge of their seat to see what kind of
decision he makes. And he decides to
walk out that to that utter darkness.
And the whole watching world cheers.
What message is that giving the watcher?
They're saying, "I don't want to be in a
perfect world. I want to go out there
where all the pain and the misery is and
walk away and turn my back on the
creator." Right? Because there's
something secret out there that I need
to know. That's right. And and so that
was, you know, that was Lucifer's
argument in the garden. Hey, you can go
out of this garden, but there was it was
death and thorns and all these things
out there. So, do they also use signs
and symbols that are, you know, familiar
to us Christians? Oh, yeah. Yeah. And
and Satan's so subtle, man. He loves to
make it look like one thing because
that's how propaganda works. It's it's
packaged in a pretty little package that
you can agree with. It's about
counterfeit basically. Yeah. Like, oh,
this movie is about creativity or it's
about, you know, racial justice or
whatever it is to get your heartstrings
attached to it. And so another movie
would be Star Wars. You know, some
people would say, I don't watch that
dark stuff. I like Star Wars where it's
good versus evil. It's light versus
dark. Mhm. But what if that's just the
propaganda? What if it's the the villain
actually has all these character traits
of Christ and the good guy actually has
more in common with Satan. So you look
at somebody like Darth Vader, they call
him Lord Vodder,
father. They're calling him Lord. I
never thought about that. Yes. And his
outfit, he's literally wearing something
very similar to what the high priest
would wear. And his the ephod. Yeah. and
he's wearing the chest plate with these
colored buttons on it. And if that
sounds like a stretch to people, then
when you go to the the conventions, they
actually bring the outfit that was on
the movie. And when you get a close-up
look of the outfit, between those
buttons is Hebrew writing. Now, why
would an alien from a far distant galaxy
long, long ago have Hebrew written in
between his buttons on his chest plate?
Good point. Um, his army, his military,
you know, he's the ruler of an empire.
And an empire is is a whole system
controlled by one person. And when you
look at his military, it's all in
perfect order. The stormtroopers are all
dressed in perfect white. But then your
side and the mind associates that with
light and goodness. Yeah. Purity and all
that and order. And when you watch the
movies and if you look at the Wikipedia
here, it says that Anakin, which is
Darth Vader when he was younger, he is
the prophesied chosen one. M. So we're
talking about Jesus and right we're
talking about prophecy now. So he was
the chosen one that was prophesied the
father Lord Vodder with the ephod and
and they call him Lord. So in the comic
and in one of the movies he somebody's
watching him fight and they're like oh
the force is strong with this one. Who
was his father? And the mother answers
and said there was no father. I can't
explain it. I was just pregnant and here
he is. So he literally was born unto
maybe not a virgin but had no father, no
earthly father. Earthly father, right?
How can we look at this as as Darth
Vader is Satan? There's no way to look
at it that way. So what about the good
guy? Well, his name is Luke, which means
light, which could be good, but we know
that Lucifer was also the lightbearer,
and he is over the rebellion. The good
guys are actually called the rebellion.
Right. Right. and they're all chaotic
and they're going against the empire.
They're resisting the empire. So, it's a
misportray of Jesus anyway because he
didn't come when he came. He didn't come
to start a revolution. That's right. He
was a peacemaker. And so, it all this
gets tied in. These are more like adult
movies, but it it goes into a lot of
children's films and and the message is
just so different. It's like think about
the movie Frozen. Mhm. So, there's a
song, a very famous song in the movie
called Let It Go. You don't want to hear
me sing it, but I know what you're
talking about. And it'll be stuck in
your head all day because those those
songs are very powerful. They're
addictive. They get stuck in your head.
And you see little girls singing this
and parents clapping. Oh, that's so
good. But in the lyrics, she says, "No
right, no wrong. No rules for me. I'm
free." So, this reminds me of yoga. Uh,
it was very much open your heart, free
your heart, follow your heart, empty
your mind. Yeah. Where have we heard
follow your heart? That's Disney's
famous slogan in almost every movie is
follow your heart. They even have, you
know, ice capes and it's called the
follow your heart tour or whatever. So
that's Disney's main focus is follow
your heart. Even though the Bible says
your heart is deceitful above all things
and desperately wicked, who can who can
know it? You can't trust your heart
because your heart is emotions. It's
selfish. It's self- serving until it's
been delivered and opened unto the Lord.
That's right. And and it goes like this.
I mean, it's a roller coaster. Your
heart, you could be feeling like, "Oh, I
love this person." And the next day
like, "I can't stand that person." You
can't trust your heart. So to follow
your heart is is a satanic message. And
then the breaking of the rules in so
many movies. Um, have you ever seen
Aladdin growing up? Oh yeah. So think
about this in a we have to look at
everything through the lens of the
Bible. when we're when we're watching
things, all these princess movies, if we
are to be married to the Prince of
Peace, we're the bride of Christ, right?
That's right. What does that make us? If
we're if we're the bride of a prince,
what does that make us symbolically?
Well, chosen, holy and a princess.
Princess. So, you have all these movies
about these princesses, and in Aladdin
movie, she was supposed to marry the
prince. Her her father's the king. Our
father's a king. That's right. and he
wanted his princess daughter to marry
the prince. But in comes this thief,
Aladdin, who's literally a thief, a poor
man. And he steals an apple and he gives
it to her. And he sings a song and he
says, "I can open your eyes." This is
exactly Genesis, right? Giving her the
fruit, saying, "I can open your eyes and
I can take you to a whole new world
where no one to tell us no or where to
go." Always taking you to a world with
no rules. Peter Pan. Same thing. You
think about your pre-teen daughter up in
her room and some boy flies up there and
says, "Hey, I want to take you to Never
Neverland." This is incredible. The Lost
Boys where there's no rules. The only
thing is is you can't ever come back.
And that's also a lie because I've seen
repeatedly people testify who have come
on a wolf in sheep's clothing and they
were in the abyss of darkness. God's
hand is never t retracted from you until
you grieve the Holy Spirit. And if he
can pull those people out, he could pull
anyone out there who's struggling. Yes.
And I've been down that road as well.
There was a a movie called Wreck-It
Ralph and it was about a game system and
the main character was a carpenter named
Felix. Oh my goodness. Who's the good
guy? And I fell for it. I I totally
missed that. I did see it. I saw it and
I liked it. But think about it. He's the
good guy of Niceland, right? What a
fairy tale way of talking about heaven.
And all of them live in the penthouse.
Like none of the floors of that building
are occupied except the top floor. And
in the beginning, they show how Ralph
the bad guy was cast out of Niceland
into the city dump, which Jesus used
that as a metaphor with Gehenna. And so
the it's this whole sympathy for the
devil thing because Ralph is telling
people, you know, I was created this
way. The creator made me a bad guy, but
I wish I was a good guy. And so he
starts going to these meetings of other
bad guys, including Satan is in that
group. Psops up in that group. Yeah, I
remember that. And and they're saying,
"Whoa, don't mess with the system. This
is how you were created. You were born
this way is the new term." And even
though you'd never seen him interacting
with Satan, he was familiar with him.
Oh, hi Satan. It was very casual,
nonchalant. And
so Ralph has an agenda. He wants to get
this golden medal because he says, "If I
can get that golden medal, I can be like
Felix." So, we know that Satan said, "I
can be like the most high. I can do it
in my own strength. I don't need you or
your law." So, as he's chasing this
metal that makes him like the carpenter,
the good guy carpenter. He ends up going
to a place called Candyland. And the the
metal is hanging in a tree and he meets
a girl at the tree, Eve. You have to
think of this whole thing. You have to
look at the lens of the Bible. So, Satan
is literally interacting with a woman at
the tree and she takes the metal and
when she takes it, she glitches for the
first time. Yeah. So, now sin has been
introduced into this perfect game world
and they're being told, "Don't let the
creator of the game see that you're
glitching because if he sees you
glitching, they'll unplug the game."
Just like, you know, this is this is
really true in a sense. We know that God
has to cleanse the earth of sin. He has
to start it over and make a perfect
world again. But they're painting it in
the light that this King Candy guy is a
villain and that you don't want the
creator to see that you're glitched out
because he's going to wipe out the whole
system. You and I are both testaments
that that's not true. We were glitching,
so to speak, and God reached in and got
us. But that's not how this movie ends.
It doesn't say we can fix that glitch.
Instead, the lesson is embrace your
glitch. Because the girl swears that
she'll never glitch again. And as she's
racing, she has to win the race. So, she
uses the glitch to her advantage and
crosses the finish line ahead of
everybody. So, cheating. Cheating. Using
sin as a way to win. And then she
becomes the most picked player of the
game. So, we're starting to wind down.
Give me another example. Okay. Another
example would be a lot of the comic
movies. A lot of people are getting into
the comic movies, DC, Marvel, all this
stuff. Avengers. Yeah, it's really hot
right now. Yeah. But Batman is one that
people kind of look at, well, like, you
know, he's he's about justice and
bringing, you know, trying to make
things right, and it's a classic. It's
been around since my father's time.
Yeah. Yeah. One interesting thing, just
it's kind of a visual thing, but a long
time ago, he used to wear like blue and
gray. It was very campy and colorful and
all that. And even the the jingle to it
was like
and he had a little guy with him, a
robin. It it seemed innocent, right? And
you you watched the evolution of where
it's come today to now he's the dark
knight and literally there's not a color
on him. Even his logo used to be yellow
and now it's black or gray. So just the
imagery alone is getting darker and
darker and darker. And I thought Batman
was based off of a bat, right? But the
artist who created him said, "No, Batman
is based off of a demon." And so you
look and you see the comic books and
they're named Birth of the Demon,
Batman, Son of the Demon, Batman, Tales
of the Demon. So Batman is literally a
demon that we have made a hero. He's
glorified and and the people that he
goes against are are oftentimes have a
lot of character traits of Christ. Uh,
in Batman Returns, the penguin was born
on Christmas Day, put into a basket in a
river, and when he when he grows up Oh,
he he died 33 years later. Oh, wow. I I
did this all of this. I'm It just went
right over my head. I didn't even think
about it. Yeah. We've all been tricked
because we're not expecting to the enemy
to attack us so subtly. Yeah. And so,
you know, with Marvel, like you
mentioned, the Avengers, all these
superheroes, the the comic book creators
themselves, this is not just me. I'm not
just some religious zealot saying all
this stuff's evil. It's coming from
their own mouths. They will tell you
Batman is Hades, Aquaman is Zeus,
Hermes, you know, all these people,
Thor, these are Greek and Roman and
pagan gods, mythology being glorified,
right? Repackaged and turned into
superheroes. And this is what they're
saying themselves, right? And so when
you look at the Bible and and think
about where the Israelites kept getting
tripped up by all these pagan gods and
and God's saying, "Don't even mention
their names." And yet we're glorifying
the name Thor. And so you think of a
movie like Avengers where all over the
over time now, Satan is patient, too.
He's getting you sucked in. The first
movie, oh, it wasn't that bad. The
second movie, it was a little maybe
there was some iffy things in there. By
the third movie, you're already so
addicted to it. You're wearing the
t-shirts. You're talking about it.
You're telling people, "Oh, you got to
see it." Exactly. And you're taking
other people. So, we're evangelizing
people to this thing. We're witnessing
on behalf of the wrong doctrine. And so,
the the Avengers movie was all about
leading up to Endgame, which was we're
going to fight Thanos. And if you look
at the character traits of Thanos, he's
an immortal, all powerful god who sits
on a throne in a spaceship called the
Sanctuary. No way. And he's coming to
earth to snap his fingers and destroy
half of humanity, separating the sheep
from the goats. Yeah. This is literally
a like every aspect of him is Christ
who's sitting in the sanctuary and he
will come to separate the sheep from the
goats, the wheat from the tears. And in
the movie, all these pagan gods, Roman
gods, mutants, they come together. They
put aside their differences and say, "We
have to fight to defend Earth." And they
come together creator, the true creator.
That's right. They come together. You
know, I don't think it's an an accident
that they named it endgame. We are
literally in the end times. That's
right. But I want to turn our attention
to who is Mikey today and how is he
using his talents. I just thank God for
giving me eyes to see because even as a
new Christian, I remember rejecting this
message. I would hear people say, "Oh,
Harry Potter is pushing witchcraft." I'm
like, "It's a kids show. Let these kids
imagine." I was so blinded. You know, it
says that the God of this world has
blinded us. But if we're really seeking
for truth, we can pray to God and ask
for spiritual discernment. And in an
instant, he knocked those scales off my
eyes just like Saul on the road to
Damascus. I remember it stood me up out
of my seat December 2011. And I was just
like, I can see it all for the way it
is. And it's a gift from God.
Discernment is. But we have to desire
that. We have to desire. If it's if it
makes me have to put away everything
that I've ever loved, I just want truth.
He will answer that prayer. What's
beautiful about Christ is that he wants
to cleanse the temple so that he can be
dwelling in us, by us, and through us.
And it's just beautiful to see how he
has delivered you. That's right. Psalm
101:3 says, "I will set nothing wicked
before my eyes." You know, some people
think that if I don't do it, if I'm not
doing it, then it's not bad. But really,
we should not be entertaining ourselves
with witchcraft, heroes that are
literally Greek and pagan and Roman
gods. So, I just challenge people, ask
for discernment. Look at this template
that I've shown and see if you see this
repetitious pattern. And if you see it,
don't entertain your minds with this
stuff. Thank you so much. This is just
great information.
The Bible compels us to examine
ourselves and to work out our salvation
with fear and trembling. In the words of
the psalmist, I will set nothing wicked
before my eyes. And Job said, I have
made a covenant with my eyes. We would
do well to do the same. Remember,
everything that glitters is really not
gold. If there is temptation before your
eyes, ask for the spirit of discernment
and ask the Lord to be with you. Until
the next time, this has been a wolf in
sheep's clothing.